as long as you allow your personal
weaknesses to hold you back they're
going to as an entrepreneur I want to
see you turn those weaknesses those
weaknesses into strengths I'd help you
move your business forward hi I'm Evan
Carmichael your friend in all things
entrepreneurship and today i'm answering
a question from a young entrepreneur
named Rafael who's from New Jersey he
wants to start a software company and he
says people don't want to help him
because he's only 16 he's too young
Rafael congrats wanna start this
business as long as you feel that 16 is
too young that's gonna hold you back
it's going to limit your success I had
my first software company when I was 19
so I kind of know what you're going
through I was selling the guys to three
times my age and it scared me I didn't
want to do it at first because I thought
these guys have a lot more experience
and have a lot more knowledge they know
things that I don't know and I'm going
to look like an idiot calling all these
guys but I did it and I realized that
those are just assumptions in my head
that they weren't true people want to
help people you can use the fact that
you're 16 to your advantage two ways one
mentorship people love helping young
entrepreneurs it's a lot easier to get
help as an entrepreneur Dennis somebody
who's older so use that to your
advantage call our entrepreneurs you
respect ask them for their help say
you're a young ambitious entrepreneur
you're trying to get this business
started I'd love to pick your brain for
some ideas if you show that you are
really passionate about it they're gonna
say yes they're going to meet with you
the other way to use it is not to feel
that 16 is holding you back with 16 is
your strength because you know what's
coming up you're up to date with the
technology you're the next wave people
should be hiring you because you're 16
companies who are out of date with
technology and looking for the next
thing this should be looking at you and
that's how you should be presenting
yourself
use the fact that you're young to your
advantage and don't let it hold you back
you want to start a software company I
don't know how much you know about
software but as long as you are
providing a lot of value to your
customers and you're pouring your heart
into it you're going to make a lot of
money for those of you are watching
Rafael's problem is the limiting person
belief around age but it applies to
everything we let our limiting person
believes hold us back some people is age
I'm too young or too old some people's
education I never went to university
some people's experience whatever it is
it's just in your head and you can use
it to your advantage to get customers
and that's part of being a successful
entrepreneur you got to turn your
weaknesses into your strengths as a way
to grow your business it's just shifting
a mindset I hope you'll apply to your
business thank you everybody for
watching if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up below makes you want
to do more for you and if you have a
comment I'd love to hear from you in the
comments section below thank you and
I'll see you soon
you
you